don't be scared to change your KNE the
most important thing is authenticity and
if you're feeling like you don't want to
do this anymore your audience are going
to see and they're going to drop off
anyway I grow from 10 to 100,000
subscribers in one year and I would 100%
put that down to uploading three times a
week every single week for a year just
do the best you can do upload it be
consistent and I do guarantee you Brands
will find you well back to the think
media podcast in this episode we're
going to be talking about tips for
creating content as a parent now even if
you're not a parent uh you're going to
learn some productivity strategies and
lots of nuggets but our guest Vanessa
Canby is a mother of three she's living
in Scotland and creating content
globally and locally she's going to be
breaking down some tips on how to find
your Unique Style and voice on YouTube
her experience with working with Brands
uh tips for filming and editing content
and a lot of nuggets that are going to
help you reach your goals faster on
YouTube Vanessa welcome to the show
thanks so much for having me it's kind
of surreal talking to you because I
literally learn how to be a YouTuber
partly through watching your videos so
it's so strange to I be talking to you
now well it's an honor to have you on
the show in fact the way I discovered
you was I was looking through
subscribers I think of think Media or
the think media podcast just kind of
curious uh you know what people wore up
to and reached out and I'm so grateful
was very fascinated uh by your story
which I don't know a ton of and so today
you have 172,000
subscribers when did you start and what
has kind of been happening since the
beginning of launching your YouTube
channel where were you living and what's
happened since then so I started my
YouTube channel in 2017 the reason why
it's interesting that you talk about
parenting is because I wanted to find
something I could do whilst being a
present Mother at home so I just had my
second child she was just born and I
decided you know what I'm going to start
a YouTube channel I was literally lying
in bed my pillow was on the head and I
thought let me start it I ordered a
camera then and there it was the Canon
g7x Mark I I think at the time and I
just literally Dove right into looking
up how to edit how to film and honestly
getting started is just the best thing
to learn how to do it as you go along
and so at that time I started doing
Vlogs about family life and then I went
to Ghana which is where my dad's from in
West Africa on a trip for my cousin's
wedding and I thought do you know what
let me just do a video whilst I'm there
and that video did amazingly it got
something like 100,000 views at the time
my videos were probably getting a
thousand views at a push tonight so that
video quickly got a lot of views and I
realized how h on a second people want
to see Ghana and it's my favorite
country in the whole entire world I've
been going there ever since I was 2
years old you know the culture is
incredible and often in Western media
you see a very negative perception of
Africa and the sort of poor side and so
I wanted to show another side there's
also a lot of African-Americans who are
interested in moving back to Africa you
know where their roots are from and so I
was really showing those people what's
possible there how you can live your
life and so basically what ended up
happening because I had two children I
couldn't really at that point so
basically what I did was I would go for
two weeks to Ghana and create six months
of content so I would go for two weeks
and film every single day I'd film about
you know as many videos that I could in
a day taking just the smallest of things
you know I'd eat in a restaurant I'd
make a whole video out of it I'd just
make as much content as possible in two
weeks and then over 6 months I would
edit it and then 6 months later I would
go back for 2 weeks and then I would
edit it again for the next 6 months and
honestly that I found to be the best way
to make content because since then I've
done it differently I then decided to
move to Ghana with my family which was
incredible I took the two kids they went
to school there it was what I always
wanted I wanted them to experience life
there but trying to live have your
family create content my husband started
working with me as well so he was a
videographer the editor honestly it was
a lot I me like working with your
partner is a lot I mean I love my
husband so much but working together was
very interesting especially when we're
trying to look after the kids as well so
and then I've just had my third child
and we moved back to Scotland to
basically have the baby and and things
like that so yeah that's kind of the
journey that I've been on wow that's
amazing and I want to unpack a couple
things take me a little bit back to what
was happening in your mind because you
said as soon basically as you got
pregnant you then were like I want to
start a YouTube
channel yeah so yeah what was kind of
what lit that fire wanting to share the
memories um wanting to document family
feeling inspired to step out like what
was the connection
between um you know moving in motherhood
and being like I have to start a YouTube
Chann Channel and then having the
commitment to be like I'm ordering a
camera now like I'm like that that
moment seems like was did you think
about it for a while or what was kind of
emotionally happening
then so my daughter was I think she was
about seven or eight months old and it
wasn't actually to do with documenting
memories for me it was very much a
business decision I I'd previously I've
done so many things in my life but the
first thing that I've done before this
was I had a juice company so I was
making cold press juices I was selling
them to cafes I was selling them to um
like at farmers markets and stuff like
that and it was a very labor intensive
job and I decided that I wanted to do
something that I could do from home so
that is actually the fact that I was a
mother I wanted to be at home with my
children and also work was the reason
why it actually wasn't anything to do
with document memories and I think
that's why it was easy for me to change
niches it wasn't that I was really
passionate about being a family vlogger
I knew that I wanted this to be my
career and I did want to share a message
that would help others it just it I just
wanted to know what people wanted help
with basically and so that's it was this
dream and of working from home which is
so cool about YouTube because it gives
us the ability to to be with family and
when you started it was family Vlogs
motherhood but then the niche kind of
pivoted to Ghana basically yeah so
actually when I was doing the family
this family Vlogs and that sort of thing
you know there was certain things that
were definitely more like popping than
others like travel something that I love
to do which now I'm actually again
changing my Niche into being a family
travel global travel not just Ghana
Channel and so travel did really well
like you know hotel reviews things that
people are going to search for um
because people when they're going on
holiday like myself I will watch so many
videos about the place I'm going to go
before I go there my husband hates doing
that because he's like I don't want to
ruin it but for me I know that's what I
like to do so I know that other people
are going to want to do the same so you
know room tours Hotel tours about
specific destinations locations that did
well but I realized obviously people
didn't care about my family Vlogs
because who cares about me when they
didn't know anything about me um so you
know anyone that's asking for advice I
would just say unless you've got a huge
family you've got 10 children people
love that stuff I love that but you know
if you're just kind of normal with a
couple kids people don't care unless
you've already built your audience
that's brilliant and there's a lot of
nuggets in there talking about the power
of of search based content the power of
travel content also kind of you would
you agree you've now kind of gone
through three distinct Niche
changes but they've been somewhat
aligned or quite a bit aligned and so
your audience has grown with you there's
kind of been a progression what's kind
of your thoughts for someone who is
considering am I in the right Niche or
not or that's thinking about pivoting
their Niche so changing Niche is a very
scary thing when I went from parenting
to Ghana I had a few thousand
subscribers and at that time that felt
like a lot of subscribers you know I
felt like oh my gosh what if I change to
Ghana and all those subscribers stop
following me you know what if they don't
care about me anymore but actually what
I've learned is you change and you gain
so many more subscribers and those
people if they're still interested in
you they'll keep watching but if they if
they're not interested it doesn't matter
because you're gaining a whole new
audience and you just never know really
how how big your audience can get and if
you are interesting people will care and
want to follow along some of the people
that used to follow me back from the
parenting Vlogs that have nothing to do
with Ghana aren't you know weren't
previously interested now know so much
about it and like DM me saying oh I
never knew this you know because I guess
if it's interesting content those people
will follow along so I just say it don't
be scared to change your Niche
especially when you feel like whatever
you're doing isn't right for you any
anymore because the most important thing
is authenticity and if you're feeling
like you don't want to do this anymore
your audience are going to see and
they're going to drop off anyway so you
may as well change into the niche that
you really want to do and then you did
you first off do one GH video noticed
that it got 100,000 views and Then
followed like we like to say success
leaves Clues make part twos so you were
like you didn't just make a part two you
kind of just were like let me make over
100 videos or whatever it is about GH
after you saw the success of a
particular place particular information
your style all resonating it's like it
all aligned and then you double down on
what's working is that kind of how it
happened yeah that is exactly what
happened I also realized that there
wasn't many people doing quality content
about Ghana and so I saw that there was
this huge gap in the market and that I
knew that I could fill it in a good way
so I just decided to just go all in and
it really really worked in my favor and
also in the favor of like so many people
say thank you so much for making this
content I didn't know about x y and Zed
so I think people are grateful that I've
made that content and I'm I'm also
thankful to be able to make it because
it's somewhere I love and I love to
share it with the world these are some
powerful questions as uh the listeners
can ask is you know what kind of
search-based content could I create what
are people looking for like maybe are
they looking for room tours Hotel tours
is there anything search based related
to my Niche and then asking what Niche
or what Gap is there in the market that
someone isn't creating quality content
for yet very powerful to think about um
maybe there's content maybe there's some
videos out there but if it's
not high effort if it's not quality
spotting a gap in the market moving into
that Gap tell me a little bit more now
during this season where you're filming
in Ghana kids started to be born and
grow up but were you going by yourself
for the two weeks to be really focused
and to produce content yeah exactly so
what I realized is when my children are
around like I am very much kind of
focused on them more than work so for me
it's good to take myself out of that
sort of environment and just like do two
weeks of intense filming and then that
means for the next 6 months
I can really be present with the kids I
hired an editor who could edit the
videos most of the time I also edited
some of the videos so I'd normally get
the editor to edit the videos up to a
certain point they'd send them to me and
then I'd kind of finish them off um so
really it didn't take okay again apart
from two weeks of intense filming which
was very tiring but you know I enjoyed
it apart from that for the next six
months didn't really have to do that
much yeah it's a that's a very power
powerful strategy to
consider would it be possible to block
two weeks on your schedule to do
absolutely in intense amount of filming
that allows you to post content for the
six the next six months and there's
probably some OB objections people have
sometimes people I think question like
recency maybe they feel like if they
didn't go to the restaurant yesterday
and the video doesn't come out tomorrow
then it's too late to publish but what
did you find with the fact of dripping
two weeks of filming over six
months like time so people didn't people
didn't know you know it wasn't like I
was writing in the caption this was four
months ago you know people really and I
I also wasn't lying so like on my
Instagram is more my upto-date
day-to-day situation you know I'm in
Scotland um so if you're really
following me across the platforms you're
going to know that I'm back in Scotland
but if you're not you're probably just
going to think that I'm still in Ghana
and a lot of these things aren't time
sensitive so you know going to a hotel
that's not shutting down it doesn't
really matter if it was this month or
two months ago or you know interviewing
somebody about their the largest
pineapple farm in Ghana that's not going
to change over the next couple of months
so honestly it's not as important unless
you're doing something like New Year's
Eve or you know something that's very
time specific it doesn't matter and I'd
say now because I don't do that anymore
and I've not done it in a long time I
can also get caught up in I oh no that's
old like that footage that footage is
old like should I really post it what
I've learned is it doesn't matter it's a
really powerful Insight there's a lot of
creators listening to this that are
sitting on content probably on their
hard drive that maybe they thought was
irrelevant but is still very much
postable and for the viewer they're
experiencing it in real time the actual
time is the time they start to watch it
unless of course it's actually a timely
event but there's so much more evergreen
or at least longer shelf life type of
content and one of the things I noticed
on your channel was some of your videos
it seemed like almost fed like HGTV
level like welcome you're standing
outside like somebody else was helping
film did that happen a few times like
how did you pull those ones off no like
as in that's just I think I so I was
actually part of the YouTube black
Creator class of 2021 which me and
YouTube black basically chose 100
creators a year for I think it was three
years I think they've I don't know if
they' finished it yet but they're still
going they decided to during the era of
George Floyd dedicate I think it was
like a $100 millionar to Black creators
and so we got seed funding um we got
training and a lot of great stuff from
YouTube like honestly I love YouTube I
feel like they really support their
creators and with that money I literally
just spent on on gear so I spent a lot
of money on just really expensive
equipment and I think you know other
people spent their money in different
ways but for me it was so important to
get that really high quality footage
audio and all the rest of it because I
feel like that's one of the most
important things like what you're saying
is like it's almost like HGTV I mean it
was my husband who learned to fil you
know had no experience of it behind the
camera we just really learned we bought
we bought TV audio equipment and like
the mics and everything is what they use
on on TV and we just went all the way
with it do you know what I mean I just
don't do things in half so I feel like
if you're going to do it you may as well
do it properly yeah that's that's wild
so sometimes there was a few times he
did travel with you and helped film and
then also times he helped edit so that
was when we moved so so initially I
would go two weeks film and then after
like a year and a half of doing that we
decided to move to Ghana and that's when
he actually left his job he had a really
highflying job because I was I was
making really good money like he left
his job and came and worked with me um
and we went and did that together gotcha
and so then
eventually when you were doing so
previous to moving there um when you
would film for two weeks and then have
six months of content sometimes you
would sit home sit back at home spend
time with the kids edit a video when you
needed to what editing software did you
use I Ed Final Cut Pro and then you you
mentioned you also found an editor did
you find somebody online that you would
delegate to no that was someone in G so
that was someone in Ghana that I worked
with I think for me it was quite
important to work with local people in
Ghana as well and not just work with
random people online I love that so you
found a a local person but then you were
working remote with them yeah so I mean
that did did have its challenges in
terms of internet upload speed internet
upload speed but because yeah but
because it's the same time zone that was
good and because we weren't like really
time pressured because we were dealing
with so many videos it didn't matter so
much about the the upload speeds Because
by the time that's come to me I could
kind of just finish editing it hey in
just a second we're going to get back
into the episode but if you haven't
heard for a limited time you can get on
demand access to my YouTube strategy
class entirely for free at think
masterclass.com on the class you're
going to learn the one strategy that we
use at think media that is currently
generating over 300,000 views every
single day if you are new to YouTube
this is going to help you start right
and avoid mistakes and if you're already
a pro this is going to help you multiply
your growth and the cool thing is the
class is 100% free and you can watch it
instantly on demand all you got to do is
go to think masterclass.com or just
click the link Link in the show notes to
get instant access all right let's jump
back into the episode what would you
attribute like to somebody that has an
aspiration to get a silver play button
100,000 subscribers plus when you look
back over things that triggered growth
you may have already mentioned a few but
if you listed it out like I feel like
these three things five things all kind
of contributed to a collection of
ingredients that ended up producing
the growth your Channel's experience uh
experienced what are those elements so I
grew from 10 to 100,000 subscribers in
one year and I would 100% put that down
to uploading three times a week every
single week for a year no breaks and
creating quality content so you know
crisp footage great audio and also
leaning into a niche fully you know
choosing one Niche sticking to it and
looking for what that audience wants and
making searchable content I used to try
and put three different titles in the
title say break that Downes you used to
so so let's say so let's say um let me
try and think of an example okay so
let's say I was doing a hotel tour in in
Ghana so I would I would maybe write
hotel toana and then there would be like
a dash and then it would say the hotel
and then there would be a dash and then
it would be like places to stay in Ghana
so I would make sure that depending on
what you're searching it's going to come
up yes that's uh for searchable Content
that is a super power tip to to stack
efficiently inside of the title the
different specific angles that someone's
searching might be searching for so
10,000 to 100,000 subscribers in a year
uploading 3 days a week no breaks three
videos a week
no breaks quality content leaning into a
niche fully searchable really figuring
out what the audience wants that is a
wild run um did you find after that that
you needed a break and did you slow down
a little bit after that year and what
have you learned about taking breaks and
periods of rest as a content creator so
I've not uploaded in the last year
because I had a baby and I like when I
was pregnant I was feeling sick and then
I had the baby and then it was just too
much and what I've realized because now
I've done a year of it is your videos
are still up you can still make passive
income for a very long time without
creating content but it does end up te
tethering off I'd say for the first8 to
nine months personally I was making you
know a good full-time income um but then
it does start to like tether off and so
I think you can take breaks definitely
but you're just not going to keep
consistently making certain amount of
money yeah you know and and what I've
done actually because
YouTube it takes a lot of energy because
I want to do it properly I don't want to
just like upload a video today which I
could do and then take you know two
months break and then upload when I
upload I want to make sure I'm uploading
consistently so that my audience doesn't
just think what are you doing um I went
over to Instagram and Tik Tok and
decided you know this is kind of what I
can manage at the moment making short
form which yeah I definitely should be
uploading to YouTube shorts if anyone
from YouTube is watching but I've been
uploading on you know Instagram reals
Tik Tok and I kind of decided to take
that a bit more seriously so I uploaded
every day for um 30 days on Instagram
because I've never taken Instagram
seriously I just wanted to see what
would happen and it was actually very
interesting like I got a lot of High
view videos and one of them would take
it back to a point of old footage I used
a video from about four years ago made
it into a 5sec reel just wrote over the
top um share this to somebody you want
to go to Ghana with 500,000 views wow
you know it probably took me about two
minutes to make the video obviously I
found trending trending music I just saw
what was what was going through the
reals you know when you when you go on
reals you see what's coming again and
again and again and you can just take
that and apply it to your Niche and in
and I'd say short form content is just
takes much less energy and there's times
in your life when you don't have the
energy to be making long form content
and that's encouraging I think to look
at the span of of like six years since
2017 of times of intense hustle times of
intense travel for two weeks and then
edit for six months moving there like it
really speaks to different seasons that
we can go through as a content creator
and then it's also encouraging to think
about the momentum you build on YouTube
really can pay you passively like you
mentioned it tapers off but when you
said you had about eight to nine months
of full-time income even though you
stopped uploading was that just from you
yeah and I wasn't doing any I wasn't
doing anything like I literally wasn't
uploading I was just you know being
pregnant having a baby which is amazing
that's a huge amount of time to have
that sustain and was that just from
YouTube ad
Revenue yeah just the the AdSense yeah
that's really cool and and then
obviously the power of short form and I
would totally agree short form does take
less energy and so doing something
that's manageable of course a big
opportunity that if you are creating
short form on Instagram and Tik Tok that
you could also put it on shorts or
multi-purpose it around different
platforms and I think that um the amount
of opportunity for any who has years of
footage to turn in previous footage even
from their phone too into current
vertical video is off the charts I think
probably what would hold most people
back including myself as I think through
it is finding the footage having time to
review it and being organized enough to
find it have you stayed very organized
or how did you
absolutely absolutely Ely not I'm even
trying to think how I so that video was
on my phone so I I literally just
scrolled all that all the footage that
I've used on Instagram has been footage
that I've filmed on my phone and it's
really taught me now to film a lot on my
phone you know like as much as I'm
filming on my proper camera to film
everything vertical cuz there's still
not a good camera that can film vertical
and horizontal you know what I mean that
can film both ways is and it just
delivers it to you in two different
files which is what I'm looking for
anyone out there that makes cameras yeah
you know what's also kind of crazy is
obviously not everybody has the newest
phone but phones are also they're
already so great but what's really wild
to me was Apple just had a recent event
where they were talking about the new
M3 MacBook
laptop and the event started the CEO Tim
Cook comes out with smoke and mist and
they do all their announcements and it
just it looks beautiful everything like
that Apple does is all premium Le shot
and then after the credits of the event
the event was over the end of the video
said this entire event was shot on an
iPhone 15 and previously they used AR
Alexa cameras which were
$100,000 cameras to film their apple
events but now this most recent one um
was shot irely on an iPhone revealing
that iPhones can make their way now onto
the sets of Netflix shows and Hulu shows
and proper films so naturally that's the
latest and greatest phone but it that's
a that's wild and and it speaks maybe
also how expensive an iPhone could be
but a lot cheaper than $100,000 for an
Ari
Alexa um and what it actually can pull
off with the pro reses and everything so
that is one personal thing that I'm
doing as well and you're inspiring me is
I'm
using my phone to capture a lot
especially if I'm traveling and
especially if you don't post even if you
don't post it but if I'm traveling
there's footage you could use later to
storytelling memories and uh that's
really inspiring to tap to up our
vertical video game for everybody that's
listening and I and I also actually like
I used to only I was kind of like a
quality snob like I would only ever use
my camera to film but then I went to um
I've traveled to some places that some
people might say are dangerous but I had
no problem in these places and you know
my dad was like do not bring your camera
there and so I was like okay fine I'll
just take my phone and I filmed the
videos on my phone not one person
complained about the quality and they
got like hundreds of thousands of views
I also went on another trip with my
friends like my girlfriends and filmed
all on my phone just because I didn't
want it to be you know a real content
trick and that video I think it's got
like 350,000 views and again
nobody like um complained about the
quality and I think what I realized is
it's more me that cares about the
quality than a lot of the viewers
because people are watching videos on
their phone I mean I watch YouTube
videos on my phone yes and what do you
remember what phone that was and what
were you doing for audio when you didn't
bring your proper
camera I just it was just the the
YouTube H the the phone's audio like I
didn't add any specific things I've
literally just used my phone gotcha and
yeah what phone was it at the
time so um probably a 13 iPhone 13 or an
iPhone before that would have maybe been
10 X Y amazing that's a case in point
and and at the end of the day sometimes
there is a discrepancy between how many
views we can get and the quality of the
production ultimately the content value
is definitely more important than the
production value um if the viewer is you
know pumped or gets information they
want or connects with you that's all
that's really what counts um but I think
there's also some power to uh and and a
strong point you make related to
pursuing high quality footage high
quality audio because that speaks as
well I'm curious what has been your
experience working with YouTube a little
bit unpack that and you have
collaborated with YouTube you were part
of that did you also work with Google in
some way I know Google owns YouTube but
what are some of the things that maybe
you've learned and
experienced with Google and YouTube so
I've worked with them quite a few times
um so I've worked with Google during the
lockdown I made this film they
commissioned me to make a short film I
think it was one minute and I had
complete creative control h they
basically just gave me a poem and wanted
me to relay it in in there and for them
for I can't remember where they were
putting it but it was on website like on
Google's website somewhere I think it
was maybe a blog or something like that
I'm working with the so that was one
time I've also worked with them um in
terms of like sharing my story that they
were going to share uh they've also put
me in British Vogue which was amazing
and honestly working with YouTube and
Google I've worked with so many
companies over the years that they are
definitely one of the best companies
they actually also flew me to Ghana last
year to go to the global citizen
Festival you know I just feel like every
time I work with them first of all it's
it's always again like high quality
events if I've ever been to one of their
events they take them so seriously you
know the food's
excellent the goodie bags are excellent
they just really take a lot of time and
effort obviously there's they have teams
that are working on these things um but
working with them has been great you
know and they pay really well and they
just really value people I think that's
amazing to hear about some of those
experiences and you mentioned you've
worked with lots of different brands
what has been your experience with doing
Brands and sponsorships and what are
your tips for the Creator that would say
I would love to get started but I don't
really know where to start with like
brand deals so what I would say is for
me personally a lot of them have just
come into the inbox um so they've just
emailed me and I'd say that is down to
just creating good cont content good
quality content that people can find
like right now you know I'm talking to
you Sean and you know it's just and
without me creating that content this
would have never happened you're not
just going to find me by me sitting in
my bedroom thinking
about hitting up brands or working with
Brands you have to just go ahead and
make the content that you think Brands
would like to start off with and so just
do the best you can do upload it be
consistent and I do guantee you Brands
will find you apart from that if Brands
aren't finding you and you honestly
think that your content is worthy of
Brands then I would say reach out to
them I've reached out to some huge
brands that have worked with me honestly
some of the world leading Brands even
recently that I've said to myself I'm
not going to reach out to them because
why would they want to work with me and
then I I just pluck up the courage and
do it and they actually respond and and
one work with me so I think that a lot
of people will be thinking the same
thing that these brands that want to
work with me and so a lot of people
aren't reaching out to them so actually
if you do reach out to them if you find
the right people you know search on
LinkedIn for the right PR person um get
their actual email address don't just
email you know info@ google.com do you
know what I mean like you know find the
right person get to them tell them what
they want to know if there's an area you
can tell if let's say they've launched a
new product they've launched a new
service say that you want to show that
off in this way you know you have to
know about the brand show that you care
and these people have marketing budgets
they do actually want to push their
products in their services so if you can
show them that you're going to do that
they're G they're going to work with you
so much inspiring advice there
especially about having the courage to
um reach out and don't allow your selft
talk to hold you back if you are making
serious content and you're being
consistent and you're uploading it how
would they know if you don't ask I'm
curious you just slide into their DMS
did you try to look up the marketing
director and send them an email um what
what was your way of reaching out to
some of the ones that you reached out to
so some brands have specific influencer
Pages these days um and so if you start
looking into the brands you want to work
with and you see they've got an
influencer page an influencer form I
would fill that out if they don't have
that they might have a press room that
you can contact directly I've actually
emailed a company and CCD in three
different people two people have said no
and one person said yes so it just shows
you you know just have to get to the
right person because some people might
see you and think no but then you get to
the right person they're like wow this
is amazing did you did you and did you
BCC so they didn't see their yeah so
like so you just sent the one
email blind carbon copy BCC three
different people that work there two
replied and said no not interested and
one said yes and then you got the
deal yeah no exactly it's
amazing and what I wonder is how does
that work out when the other people see
it and like hang on a second um I mean
all the the takeaway too is like Just
Having the courage to go for it reach
out multiple times make great content
keep moving forward
you know and have kind of that mentality
of I'm I'll keep asking or be creative
in how I ask I'm curious from your point
of
view living in Scotland right now all
this time in Ghana you've traveled the
world um it's easy and sometimes I think
Americans can
have an a relevant stereotype that the
world has that sometimes we're ignorant
or we don't really kind of know what's
happening in the world cuz a lot of
times we don't like we sort of you know
have just a mindset we know what's
happening in our world and we know
what's happening in you know North
America I'm just kind of
curious what maybe misconceptions you've
noticed or what you think content
creators in the US should know about
creating content
internationally take this question
anywhere you want I'm just curious like
what should what do you wish us creators
would know is there opportunities around
the world is there ignorance that we
should be more aware of from your just
having a perspective from where you
are so I think these days there is more
people going to different places around
the world and showing the reality of
what's going on there and previous to
these times of us creating content you
know the news could tell you that this
is going on somewhere and we would just
kind of have to believe it because
there's not going to be real people on
the ground sharing the true message and
so we're in such an incredible time that
we can actually share our own voices on
a free to upload platform to millions of
people and so I think it's so important
to really share your own truth and your
own story wherever that may be and if
you do want to travel you know like I
think it's great to go to places that
aren't
highly um uploaded so there is some
places that EV you know everyone's been
there and I'm not saying that you
shouldn't do that you can also do that
but I think it's also nice to see places
that that people haven't seen before as
much um and show that side of things but
I also honestly think like even taking
it back to your own house there'll be
things that you've searched before that
haven't come up to this day I search
things on YouTube and there isn't videos
for them so it shows me that I could
literally search that thing there's no
video decided okay I'm just going to
make that video upload it and it could
do amazing because just nobody else has
done it so I just think it's just really
important to just share yeah and I love
I love you sharing that I I feel the
same way it's shocking that in a like a
World that we could go to YouTube and
not find something but that speaks to
the massive opportunity for everybody
listening that if you there's still not
only is there still topics from the past
or products or locations or hotels or
restaurants or country
um but there's also new things happening
all the time so this whole opportunity
of getting discovered um is a lot more
real Than People realize once you
develop kind of like the YouTube
eyesight to be able to perceive discover
and then create videos to answer
specific questions and tapping into the
power of search based content I want to
do a segment as we land the plane called
repeat after me so I'll say the
beginning of a sentence you just kind of
finish the sentence and are you ready
yeah I'm ready so if I was starting in
YouTube from scratch today the first
thing I would do is if I was starting a
YouTube channel from scratch today I
would upload three times a week
consistently for an entire year the
number one piece of advice I have for
new content creators is the number one
piece of advice I have for new content
creators is to buy quality content or if
it's just your phone make sure it's well
lit one of the best ways to improve your
videos is one of the best ways to
improve your videos is to have good
lighting and also make sure that you
have good audio whenever I have felt
tired or like quitting YouTube this is
what I've done whenever I felt tired or
quitting YouTube this is what I've done
I've taken a break it's smart it's good
advice um tired eyes rarely see a bright
future and uh taking a nap is sometimes
the most strategic thing you could ever
do yeah um you've added so much value
Vanessa on this podcast really want to
acknowledge you for just the light
you're spreading in the world and the
joy that comes through in your voice and
for those that are on the video version
of the podcast uh it's been a huge
blessing having you for people that want
to check out what you're doing across
social media where can they connect with
you and what's coming up next so that's
Vanessa Canby and it's k n bi I and
what's coming up next for me I actually
just filmed a TV show over the past four
months that's going to be coming out in
2024 which I'm really excited about and
hopefully I'll do some more TV projects
and I'll be back on YouTube yes thank
you Vanessa appreciate you